on the mound for the padres is you
darvish 35 year old veteran 25th start
and uh last time out two two thirds a
rough outing he needs to turn it around
there you see the numbers on the season
140 frames thrown 167 strikeouts that's
a big part of his game
2-2 is strike three
first strikeout of the night for you
darvish
and the payoff pitch on the way it is on
the inside corner strength recall back
to back punch outs for darvish rose
fletcher with a fastball and now he does
the same to brandon mars two away
and the pitch is taken on the outside
quarter strike three called three
straight fastballs to open the night for
you darvish it'll be mike myers on the
mound for the angels the 29 year old
veteran right hander making a spot start
assignment an opener assignment if you
will
and myers benefits from the same big
zone the darvish did in the top of the
inning one out one on and it brings up
annie machado
leg back towards the plate here he chops
one to third flip to second in time
relay to first a little late
runner on first two outs and the 01 is a
slow ground ball to third base gosling
got a little bit of a late start trying
to go to the bare hand he's got no play
left the ball on the infield grass near
third base being infield single for
fernando tatis junior
popped him up
adele in from left to make a tricky play
playing small ball early here in the
second inning angels have a runner at
third
here's the 3-2 to mayfield first of all
misses off the plate ball four and the
angels have a pair on trying to get on
the scoreboard here in the second max
stassi will be the next batter
fly ball headed to right center field
falling fast fernando coming in to make
the catch tagging from third is walsh
the throw gonna be close he's gonna be
very out fernando tatis jr with an
outfield assist
oh yeah nando can do it from the
outfield too
that was some kind of nash the runner on
first nobody out for left hand hitting
adam frazier starting at second base
tonight here it is from myers and a line
drive out towards left center field
adele with a long run he's not going to
get there split the gap perfectly
meyer's got a great read on it will is
rounding 30s and a covenant score
without a play rbi double adam frazier
great base running will myers one to
nothing san diego in the second and the
padres will get themselves another base
runner here in the second inning darvish
down to second and cronenworth coming up
oh and two here's the pitch and
chronoworth swings lines it into left
field that'll be a base hit garvish is
going to be waved at third base adele's
throw comes into nobody at third it ends
up hitting grisham garvish scores and
cronenworth with an rbi single to make
it two to nothing now they are loaded
for fernando tatis jr one of the best
bases loaded hitters in all the baseball
check swing did he go no
and that'll walk in a run padres take a
three-nothing lead
on the bases loaded walk
three-nothing padres bases loaded two
out
ball four and he walks in another run
it's three walks in a row for angels
pitching rbi for hosmer
and the padres lead at four nothing
myers will now get his second at bat of
the inning
that is ball four and
unbelievable four straight walks and
another bases loaded walk padres take a
five nothing lead of course adam frazier
already doubled in this inning with an
rbi
[Applause]
and this will get away to the screen and
it scores from third base fernando tatis
jr and the padres take a six nothing
lead three and one swinging a ground
ball through the right side that's a
base hit hosmer will score meyers
rounding third he will come in to score
a two-run single for adam frazier his
second hit of the inning his third rbi
of the inning and it's eight to nothing
san diego in the second marsh gosselin
and walsh here in the fourth
there's a drive out to right field
and it gets past tatis into the right
field corner marsh never stopped he's on
his way to third
a lead off triple in the halo half of
the fourth
[Applause]
and gosselin grounds it to third machado
dropped it recovered
and loses his out marsh scores to put
the angels on the board for the first
time
[Applause]
but 75 is on the ground right side
frazier from the outfield grass spins
and fires nice play
[Applause]
popped up
foul ground carrotini and machado and
it's manny machado makes the catch right
in front of the angels dugout 302 pitch
to short and kronerworth on the run
and in time
to one two three fifth darvish is
through five eight one padre
fletcher hits it in the air to right
field straight away for tati's fernando
comes in a couple of steps and makes the
catch one out in the top of the sixth
inning
fly ball deep left field myers going
back at the wall he'll make the catch
[Music]
stays in the yard
and ready to go on two and two walsh
waits in the left-handed batters box
here's the pitch
and a swing and a maze got it with a
slider and uh darvish gets the result he
was looking for it is his seventh strike
out of the night
and two on one out for hosmer here in
the sixth inning
machado and tatis aboard with one away
and hosmer taps it to fletcher
manny now on third tucson second with
two down meyers coming up eight to one
padres in the bottom of the sixth inning
[Applause]
and he gets him looking
[Applause]
legarres with the ball well hit to left
and that one's going to go
fifth of the year for one legaures a two
run shot that makes it an eight to three
san diego lead
joe adele that's with kurt suzuki at
first base and two down here in the
eighth
to del to right field and well hit and
that one's gonna go
a pair of two run homers in the seventh
and the eighth and hasn't this gotten
interesting
situation
right back at him
lanson knocks it down then throws him
out for the first down of the ninth inn
fly ball opposite field incoming is
tatisse and that is out number two
chop to third machado plants and throws
that's the ball game padres win
you